I appreciate it
exciting exciting you see me I know but
there's other reasons to be happy we hit
I know why Democrats are happy that we
had a few off year elections on Tuesday
and Trump's guys all the people Trump
supported got their asses kicked like a
dog with the dog never anything like
what a dog does what he said but what
killed Republicans was the suburbs
anybody live in the suburbs suburbs are
coming to our rescue yeah the suburbs
are turning out truck remember when
Trump said you have to vote for me you
have no choice and soccer mom said hold
my juice box
[Music]
it's interesting Trump has never had the
cities right now he's lost the burbs he
still pulls well in the hamlets whistle
stops one-horse towns bum Fox and wide
areas of the road you know I'm the guy
who keeps saying if he loses he's not
gonna leave well we had a little dry run
for that Kentucky Kentucky elected a
Democratic governor but the previous
Republican governor is saying he's not
accepting it losing now is just fake
news get ready for this people this is
what we have we have one year to the
election get ready for this losing is
now fake news this guy is fighting it he
said there were irregularities yes there
were a reports of black people who had
been screwed out of their voting rights
voting any way
oh if you have Trump loving relatives
for Thanksgiving this year it's it's
gonna be fun because the impeachment
hearings where we actually see it they
start next week just in time for the
holidays if you get asked you know what
should I bring say Kevlar in other news
the president of united states steals
from charity did I really say that
that's the premise what [ __ ] world is
this yes I mean we knew this the Trump
foundation they've had to close it down
a couple years ago now this week would
happen a two million dollar fine and get
this I love this Ivanka Eric and Don jr.
they have court ordered mandatory
charity training
first lesson when the teacher says take
a seat they don't mean steal it the
impeachable that we don't even mention
because they're so far down the list
Trump said I can't believe this is real
he said he might go with Putin to the
May Day Parade the May Day Parade
it's the parade they celebrate communism
wins he said I was invited I'm thinking
about it he said but it's right in the
middle of our campaign season and we
know that's the busy time of year for
the Russians
it's what is so mind-boggling is it on
the heels of the colluding with Russia
that we just went through for two years
in 2016 they immediately turn around and
called Ukraine to see if they could help
with 2020 I mean this impeachment thing
keeps going people just keep testifying
every week that Trump demanded a quid PO
crow from Ukraine like they said from
the beginning I mean we've heard from
the Deputy Secretary of State the Envoy
the ambassador the diplomat the other
diplomat the it's like a game of Clue
where every single person is saying it
was the fat guy in the Oval Office
and Trump wanted Attorney General bar
when it I guess this qualifies is kind
of a bright spot if you have to look for
one but yeah he wanted Attorney General
bar to publicly declare what he has been
saying that it was a perfect call and
bar said no wow bar said no finally bar
had his meatloaf moment he said I would
do anything for love but I won't do that
yet the Republicans it's so interesting
they've put too much David demanding
that the Democrats release the
transcripts so this week that released
the transcript of the impeachment
hearings and they say the Republicans
were refusing to read them right I
didn't make that up it's kind of like
that time Trump mail ordered Melania
from Slovenia
when she came he just played with the
box you know so amidst all this this new
book is coming out called a warning by
the same guy who wrote that op-ed called
anonymous a couple of years ago some
this supposed any cider in the White
House's at the truck trombe all these
examples that he's a senile racist
dingdong who can't string two thoughts
together like that was a closely guarded
secret I want to say to this guy whoever
he is don't spoil the beginning but the
other reason why I could tell there was
extra excitement tonight on the
Democratic side Bloomberg is in sort of
in it men his age it's hard to tell
but I say good it's about time
billionaires got a voice on a place at
the table of this country he's got a
great slogan sharper than Biden richer
than Trump less Jewish than Bernie and
this is this is gonna be by far now he's
77 by far the oldest Democratic field we
ever have it could come down to
Bloomberg Biden Bernie and Tom Steyer I
don't know what the debates are gonna be
like but it won't be a pissing contest
you